bibelszenen in augsburg es ist spät am
samstagabend kurz vor mitternacht in der
innenstadt als vor einem lokal streit
und wut eskalieren
corona wut gegen das ordnungsamt und
gegen die polizeibeamten während sich
und können dann erst mit einem
großaufgebot die lage beruhigen was
genau war passiert wegen lärmbelästigung
und verstößen gegen die korona regeln
will das ordnungsamt die lokalität
schließen doch die wirtin weigert sich
und mit einigen ihrer gäste geht es dann
in eine wilde prügelei mit der polizei
es fliegen becher dann auch fäuste
schläge ins gesicht
vier beamte werden schließlich verletzt
drei so schwer dass sie laut polizei
dienstunfähig sind erst als die beamten
pfefferspray einsetzen kann die lage vom
wirtshaus beruhigt werden